[Música]
[Aplausos]
imagina se você ouvir todos os dias às
mesmas perguntas a cada vez que você
chega no trabalho na escola onde quer
que você vá ao seu dia a dia
hoje eu tenho que responder todos os
dias perguntas sobre o meu deslocamento
que é o uso que ora de volta pra casa
que meu pé
se o mário vejo essas perguntas porque
eu sou mulher andava pelas ruas da
cidade
nesse dia que eu gostei da foto da alta
e um outro olhar pra mim apontando um
estudo nesse sentido é o mesmo mas o bom
é e bicicleta com ele as pessoas pessoas
como eu que o transporte que é possível
se o já os nossos públicos
o carro um pouquinho eu sou a urbanista
e professora de urbanismo na
universidade particular de campo grande
eu tinha aqui o que eu acho mais simples
e fácil tomar o desmatamento mas acabou
tendo que responder várias questões uma
casa clássica que eu escuto é coragem
deu também uma visita dura de transporte
escutas vezes para seu cachorro grande
apenas 4.4 o centro da cidade só foi de
bicicleta apenas dois são mulheres ou
seja como eu que o transporte ou seja 10
da população
[Música]
é uma sensação de segurança ou seja no
século 19 quando eu comecei a usar o
transporte
na época eu queria apenas uma solução
mais eficiente que o adversário do que o
ônibus quando eu comecei pela bicicleta
e acabei orientando toda minha
trajetória acadêmica estudava secreto ea
descobrir que mesmo
a infraestrutura cicloviária grande é
assim possível se se aceita e respeitada
nas lojas sábado no canadá
olhou pra vencer o início de uma
política pública que favorecesse o uso
de bicicletas há dez anos atrás e
percebe que o simples fato de colocar um
na rua menos movimentada prioritário
para você escreve faz toda a diferença
para quem quer vê lá porque morei quatro
anos na unha
mas eu escolhi para fazer doutorado por
conta do buzin receita secreta
lá tudo o que você está fazendo a cidade
se torna mais simples fácil e rápido se
você tiver bicicleta ou seja os espaços
públicos da cidade das ruas da cidade é
feito em função da bicicleta é tão
apertados lugares eu percebi que não é
cachorro é ajudar bicicleta que dá
prazer você sempre trazer vital mas sim
o cachorro que prazer em estado do
espaço público entre a rua e para a
praça
nos últimos anos eu tenho trabalhado
para que mais pessoas se esse trazem
está no espaço público e que mais
pessoas reynaldinho repente os passos da
nossa sociedade
a estratégia que a gente queria o fim da
grande fome bacf a gente queria fazer um
movimento que então essa discussão do
uso da bicicleta na cidade mas que não
tivesse caráter político de manifestação
da ls inspirou no de barba e criamos de
bairro em bairro que é um passeio pelas
ruas da cidade de campina grande
visitando diferentes bairros da cidade
ea gente tem que escolher as que têm uma
relação com o espaço público seja aberta
para as ruas seja tendência nas calçadas
e ao longo de todo o trajeto a gente tem
também o direito nos acompanha observa
carreira
eu quero aqui é a casa tem mostrado que
as pessoas que participam do evento
é assim possível para lá das ruas da
cidade
aquelas histórias não são longas o pão
difíceis com parece que as pessoas
acabam relação diferente com a cidade de
deus já ganhou em velocidade de outra
forma e isso muda no dia 10
outro aspecto importante levar em maio é
que a gente ficou nesta situação e acaba
no fecho da praça pública com manifesto
a favor e foi essa que já tocou o
correto e uma das filhas como uma das
mais violentas da cidade e mesmo de
marabá que não tem ajudado milhares de
pessoas com outros movimentos do tipo
massacre como se plantada ele fez e faz
referência para as pessoas que
participam do evento
muitas pessoas acreditam que os
emprestados para ir e vir depois acaba
comprando bicicleta mas a gente já
pesquisa e mais bacana aqui metade das
pessoas que não usavam se tratem de
transporte antes de participar do baile
vai acabar usando depois participar do
evento marca ainda em que quase metade
das pessoas ou mulheres lembra que houve
apenas 2% de ciclistas eram mulheres
mas ninguém vai trabalhar com as pessoas
percebem os espaços públicos no seu
trabalhado com os alunos do curso de
urbanismo
mas o professor de urbanismo e a gvt tem
trabalhado que esses espaços públicos
ele devem ser repensados e faz fundos de
qualquer cidade não só pela grande joão
pessoa e também onde normalmente o
espaço comigo não é tão considerado
assim
daí a gente estava na velocidade que tem
em torno de 20 mil habitantes
ao final dessas disciplinas a gente
sempre faz projetos urbanos
tá leva para um lugar a pedras bacana
com sinuca
nós não fala divertido e eles têm seja
sabe domingo para desenvolver um
projecto que os espaços públicos da
cidade trabalhou sinésio e quando
provocados anos sempre me surpreende que
o projeto como então é daí que tem que
ser um lugar militantes jogador ajuda
que poderia ser melhor aproveitada ou
talvez porque existe em londres em bares
que tem 22 mil hectares
uma paisagem linda em casa o histórico
maravilhoso uma obra gigante como
abandonar quando os novos cartões esses
projetos como vocês todo mundo riu não
pode ditar da pouca calma porque
qualquer que pode ter um valor digno do
mesmo jeito perguntas ao final da
maratona
aja com vários prefeitos da cidade para
participar do júri final é muito lindo o
encantamento dos olhos deles com os
projetos que os alunos desenvolveram na
cidade deles e aí volta para casa
acreditando sim que é possível mudar os
espaços públicos da cidade além de
trabalhar na maratona
a gente criou um abandono de pesquisa
chamado laboratório erro
a idéia é fazer um projeto mais longos e
profundos dos espaços públicos de
campina grande
descobrir soluções e propor novos
projetos e mesmo isso é focar em campina
grande
os os problemas e soluções de campeão
para esse escopo seres humanos por
exemplo trabalha você comece a ela que
eu tinha que é uma discussão entre
colocar mais vagas de estacionamento
porque o comércio está complicado
escolher o congestionamento é a
mobilidade urbana o mesmo problema
qualquer cidadão mas se outras pessoas
sabem que falam que eu acho que deveria
fechar as ruas para pessoas através da
gente foi natália com as pessoas o que
elas achavam
a maioria das pessoas preferem os fatos
de calçado e espaço público
o espaço de permanência e mais metade
das pessoas que vão para o centro de
campina elas não vão comprar vão pra
passear
então olha a verdadeira necessidade de
acionamento das pessoas nunca passei
anos indo
você é mais interessante que o espaço de
competência de permanência
baseado nisso o aluno ela desenvolveu um
projeto para a rua maciel pinheiro a
principal de surf camp na hora e como
qualquer outra e 15 comercial no brasil
a gente quer o mirante do veículo fácil
de carro no estacionamento mas ela
mostrou que é simples e possível se
imaginar essa rua
o projeto assim mantém o espaço do carro
bancos e quanto mais espaços públicos
como a de conforto às pessoas de novo
quanto mais pessoas no espaço público
mais segura do poder público como você
olha a construir o espaço público da
sociedade
já pensou em até pagaria
já o mapa qual é a distância daquele
[Música]
atleta pra e inglês na academia
já o piquenique na praça no parque da
cidade precisa se lembrar quando as
pessoas jogam bola assim
já cansada e mais ainda a gente precisa
acreditar que assim possível mudança de
nossos espaços públicos e só nossa
presença deles faz toda a diferença
eu acredito que se mais pessoas usar os
espaços públicos quando bem entender
a roupa que quiser na hora que for mais
conveniente
eu vou parar de ser questionado todos os
dias sobre a minha forma eo já citado
limite
obrigada
[Aplausos]